[Musique]
pesticides pour les antilles chlordécone
herbicides au glyphosate fongicides pour
les antilles bagnols j'ai mis tout ça
dans ce vers quelqu'un veut goûter non
pourtant les doses sont dans les limites
autorisées mais en cocktail non bon
c'est légitime
avec tous ces scandales sanitaires et
écologiques
toutes ces histoires d'eau g m2
de colorants de vaccins de perturbateurs
endocriniens
c'est légitime finalement de s'inquiéter
danse de ce qu'on met à l'intérieur de
notre corps mais qu'est-ce qu'il en a de
l'extérieur du corps notre environnement
est ce que finalement nous faisons
partie d'un écosystème notre planète
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cet écosystème
est bien autour de nous en tant que
citoyen mais il ya du béton ya la ville
il ya urbanisation finalement qui
engendre des des espaces infertiles donc
moins d' espaces agricoles moins de
plantes donc moins d'absorption de gaz à
effet de serre et - d'absorption de la
pluie surtout en sous les tropiques
donc finalement qu'est ce qu'on obtient
des villes plus chaudes plus polluées et
plus inondable et qu'est ce qu'il y a
comme mécanisme dans cet écosystème
autour de nous nous consommateurs
maintenant c'est surtout vrai dans sur
un territoire insulaire d un port de
marchandises mais vous le savez les
transports maritimes sont les plus
pollueurs et pour importer quoi au fait
des produits peu comme ça qui favorise
le cancer l'obésité et plein d'autres
maladies un autre mécanisme
quand on consomme de l'huile de palme
finalement on favorise l'autre bout du
monde soit
la déforestation en asie du sud est nous
on est ici c'est pas grave oui mais moi
j'ai habité en asie du sud-est et j'ai
vu le résultat
finalement près de chez nous on peut
faire la même chose on peut grignoter
encore un petit peu là masoni en guyane
on a tellement besoin d'or qu'est ce que
ça peut faire
est ce que c'est si grave que ça de
détruire notre biodiversité c'est quoi
on perd les abeilles c'est notre plus
gros pollinisateurs on perd nos plantes
médicinales c'est nos médicaments et
finalement on perd un petit peu de
souveraineté
donc vous comprenez nous sommes
responsables
puisque nous sommes consommateurs et
nous sommes acteurs donc face à ce
constat déplorable
comment pouvons-nous manger sainement
tout en préservant l'environnement et
pour nous sortir finalement de cette
dépendance
on ose un port et est ce qu'on peut
faire tout ça quand on habite en ville
et y at il à cette pédagogie finalement
pour nous nous expliquer toutes ces
solutions et est pas pour qui elles sont
applicables
eh bien il existe des techniques
il existe des techniques pour produire
ses propres aliments
mais quand il est question d'aliments
comme des fruits des légumes et pourquoi
pas des poissons
est-ce que
ça paraît pas vraiment applicable pour
tout le monde et pourtant il existe une
technique qui s'appelle la cua pony
qu'est ce que c'est la cacophonie c'est
étymologiquement parlant c'est la
contraction de deux mots là
l'aquaculture tout le monde connaît
c'est finalement cultiver des algues des
écrevisses des oies soupe ou dans notre
cas des poissons et le deuxième os et
l'hydroponie l'hydroponie un peu moins
connus là c'est la culture de plantes
hors sol avec lequel en fait on on
nourrit les plantes directement dans les
racines et tout ça sans terre sacrée à
quoi pony et en fait cette technique à
les millénaires mais elle était connue
sous un autre nom donc comment ça marche
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'on va gérer à mini
écosystèmes pour s'en nourrir un mini
écosystème dans lequel on va retrouver
plusieurs organismes vivants pour vous
faire comprendre ça le mieux c'est de
prendre un exemple un écosystème dans
lequel on va retrouver trois organismes
et un écosystème aquatique une mare pour
ce faire pour essayer de faire simple
j'ai demandé à un grand infographiste de
vous préparer une diapo un schéma
détaillé et scientifique
milieux symbiotique donc je demande
votre attention pour essayer de
comprendre
j'espère que ça va pas être trop
compliqué alors les poissons font caca
dans l'eau voilà ce que m'a dit mon fils
quand il a dessiné sa il n'a pas tort
mais je vais expliquer un petit peu plus
donc les poissons en défavorisent dans
l'eau et se nourrissent de tout ce qui
passe des algues et du phytoplancton
c'est le vrai terme et des insectes ou
des l'art et donc ils font des petites
déjections
c'est là que ça devient intéressant
c'est ce qui l'a retenu et ses petites
déjections sont malheureusement toxiques
on appelle ça l'ammoniac c'est un type
d'azoté très toxique
et heureusement vous voyez tout en bas
il y a deux familles de gentils
bactéries là il a zoomé elles sont
beaucoup plus petites cassard en vrai et
c'est gentil bactéries vont manger le
l'ammoniac et en mangeant 7 ammoniac
avons finalement transformé cet azote en
azote beaucoup moins toxique est
beaucoup plus assimilable par les
plantes et ses plantes en mangeant cet
azote vont du coup filtrer l'eau et
épuré l'écosystème et bien en aqua pony
c'est exactement ce concept là que nous
allons copier et pour vous donner
ils ont une application concrète
on est tous capable de faire on va
prendre un mètre cube mètre cube c'est
un mètre sur un mètre sur un mètre
là ça fait mille litres d'eau on va
utiliser 1000 lits d'eau de pluie autant
utiliser des ressources naturelles dans
ces mille litres d'eau de pluie on va
produire 50 kg sur cet espace 50 kg de
poissons à l'année
autant dire un kilo par semaine
ou plutôt deux beaux poissons de 500
grammes dans votre assiette toutes les
semaines c'est pas intéressant ça pour
votre alimentation au niveau plantes en
surface proportionnelle on va produire
trois fois plus là le plus simple ça va
être des plantes aromatiques ce qui est
parfait finalement pour cuisiner vos
poissons mais aussi des tomates des
concombres des aubergines des courgettes
et des légumes racines
enfin surtout un qui aime l'eau le
madère où tu as chine et du coup même en
sols contaminés
vous allez être capable de produire ce
légume racine puisqu'on est hors sol ça
pose pas de problème donc vous pensez
pas que cette cet espace sacrifier cet
espace de vote de votre balcon de votre
terrasse ou ou ou de votre jardin vous
trouvez pas que ça vaut la peine de le
sacrifier pour produire tout ça bien sûr
il va vous falloir du matériel c'est pas
aussi simple que de que de planter en
terre mais pour exemple mon dernier
prototype a été conçu avec 90 % de
matériaux recyclés j'ai concrètement
trouver l'essentiel de mes matériaux
pour produire mes aliments dans la
poubelle au lieu de encore favoriser de
l'import
de marchandises je fais avec ce que j'ai
et finalement on valorise ce qui a à la
déchetterie ou sur le bord des routes ou
chez les industriels mais dans un
système d'aquafin il ya quoi
concrètement j'ai encore une super slide
c'est le même le même infographiste il a
7 ans il explique très bien la cua pony
donc cette fois
regardons les modules d'un système
dacquois pony et bien bien sûr on a un
bac de plantes un bac de poissons pardon
pour élever les poissons alors là il
peut être fait avec une structure
métallique une structure en bois avec du
liner ou tout simplement un aquarium est
d'ailleurs le petit carré à l'intérieur
c'est une pompe d'aquarium là il suffit
de quelques watts pour faire circuler
l'eau du système en haut à droite on a
les des modules de filtration qui sont
bien souvent des barils des barils tout
simple l'un pour clarifier l'eau est le
deuxième pour offrir un support pour nos
bactéries
c'est gentil bactérie dont on a besoin
dans ce système le dernier module sera
le module de deux cultures de plantes et
là il existe quatre techniques
différentes mais elles reprennent tout
le même la même idée
c'est finalement faire circuler l'eau du
système dans les racines des plantes
avec un retour qu'on ne voit pas les
oublier vers les poissons l'eau circule
en boucle
donc oui les racines des plantes sont
toujours dans l'eau et c'est la même eau
et non il n'y a pas du tout terre dans
ce système et pourtant ça marche
d'ailleurs c'est c'est quand ça ne
marche pas finalement
que là on réalise tout l'interdépendance
des organismes vivants dans un
écosystème
quand un seul organisme va mal tout va
mal c'est bien souvent les les animaux
qui meurent les premiers en masse alors
si vous le voulez bien faisons
l'analogie entre notre écosystème la
planète et cette petite à quoi peut ni
en tant qu'écosystème aussi nous sommes
les poissons
l'eau est notre ère et ces plantes sont
nos forêts et notre agriculture
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il se passe
si on applique une soi disant révolution
verte à ce système comme on le fait avec
la planète avec un maximum de regrets et
un maximum de d'émissions carbone et
bien si on veut pas que ce milieu
deviennent toxiques
tout simplement il suffit d'augmenter la
surface de plantes
ah oui parce que si vous avez dans un
écosystème un organisme qui finalement
nettoie votre milieu et favorise son
équilibre bien dans ces cas là cet
organisme il faut le préserver il faut
surtout pas le détruire
comme on fait même analogie maintenant
disons que on voudrait gaver les plantes
de pesticides ou tout type de produit en
side finalement produit qui tue c'est
c'est la définition là dans ce cas là
vous voyez c'est un système fermé comme
notre planète
rien ne sort nantes
bien finalement ces produits même en
petites doses se retrouverait dans le
dans l'alimentation est dans
l'environnement des poissons et vous
obtiendrez une santé de poissons pas
super en plus de ça si vous administrez
ses produits de manière régulière et en
cocktail alors là vous avez une forte
mortalité des poissons
donc j'espère que vous comprenez le
parallèle avec notre alimentation et la
façon dont on gère la planète
finalement en à quoi peut ni ce qu'on va
faire
j'espère que vous l'aurez compris c'est
qu'on ne va pas utiliser de produits
chimiques
c'est même pas qu'on ne veut pas c'est
qu'on ne peut carrément pas sinon ça ne
fonctionne pas et du coup vous êtes vous
obtenez des fruits et des légumes qui
sont exemples de produits chimiques et
qui est le plus apte que vous mêmes à
savoir que vos produits sont sans
produits chimiques puisque vous les avez
fait vous même il en est de même pour la
qualité des poissons
si on introduit d'un système des
antibiotiques
on tue toutes les bactéries et les
bonnes bactéries aussi donc c'est pareil
ça ne marche pas donc ce type de système
finalement quand vous le maîtriser vous
maîtrisez la symbiose des organismes
vivants et vous savez du coup que vos
aliments sont sains puisque vous les
avez produit vous même d'ailleurs
on peut se demander comment finalement
les pourquoi on a choisi des modèles de
gestion de la planète tels qu'ils sont
alors qu'on a des exemples très très
simple en mer ou en terre nous avons
fait des programmes pédagogiques avec
les enfants ou nous leur montrons
comment comment gérer ce type de système
et leur montrer comment les poissons de
la cantine ne sont pas tous carré est
pas né là les poissons il les élèves ils
les observent ils observent leur
croissance ils observent leur
comportement et finalement il se perd un
espèce de respect envers l'animal qui
est tout autre que celui qu'on retrouve
dans l'industrie agroalimentaire et si
vous êtes sensible à ça va peut-être
vous êtes végétarien
dans ce cas là laissez moi vous dire que
et bien un poisson comme la carpe koï
qui est un poids sur ornementale fait
aussi des petites déjections et en plus
il a une valeur marchande plus élevé que
le poisson comestibles donc en fait on a
quoi pony en plus vous ajoutez de la
végétation sur votre lieu de travail ou
sur votre lieu de vie et il existe des
des systèmes qui sont conçus pour faire
de l'ombre
en fait faire des murs végétaux donc de
l'isolation mais d'isolation comestibles
d'autres systèmes sont faits pour
éduquer les enfants à
à produire les aliments qu'ils vont
mettre dans leur assiette ou d'autres
systèmes sont conçus pour valoriser les
produits d'un restaurant du coup par la
même occasion sa optimise les la
logistique en circuit très court avec
des produits très frais ils sont à
portée de main en fait en aqua pony
toutes les tailles sont possibles du
plus petit meuble de jardin à la grande
ferme
on peut imaginer toutes les dimensions
d'ailleurs là le premier système urbain
que j'ai visités étaient toutes en haut
d'une tour ils produisaient 12000 qui
est de basilic et de menthe et c'était
en plein coeur de singapour sur autre
chose lourde pour ceux qui connaissent
j'y ai vécu plusieurs années j'ai fait
toute ma carrière à l'étranger
là bas j'étais expert en matériel
bancaire rien à voir
j'ai parcouru le monde je prenais
l'avion à peu près tous les tous les
mois pour mon travail et je dois dire
que cette ancienne vie de jeune cadre
dynamique expatriés a vraiment lombez
mon bilan carbone mais il n'est pas trop
tard pour changer pour finalement
décider prendre sa vie en main de faire
les choix qui nous sommes le plus juste
pour notre famille pour notre
environnement
c'est encore une fois par soi-même
connaît le mieux servi pour nous ouvrir
l'esprit la conscience à notre place
dans cet écosystème
moi même j'ai décidé donc de me former à
la cua pony à la végétalisation
j'ai décidé de faire un virage à 180
degrés dans ma vie
et de faire ma part de petit colibri en
transmettant un savoir j'espère que vous
même vous serez capable d'ouvrir cette
porte qui mène à l'action concrète et il
n'est pas trop tard pour vous demander
ce que vous faites vous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]